when did you get started my ex-boyfriend
surgery isn't cheap come pick me up when
I was aging out of foster care of meth I
was stripping and switched over I'd like
to make an appointment as she available
tonight I just got a call you're working
tonight
yeah yeah you could just answer a few
questions and be truly honest brutally
honest
do you like what you do I like being
good at what I do
when I'm with a client I'm exactly what
they want you're a fan of the client
Jelena
we're going to a party because you hate
everybody there and you want them to
know that you're dating a prostitute
correct ready to get weird fancy hi I'm
Chloe's father this is my girlfriend Kat
and what do you do well I model for your
daughter news mostly oh my god it must
have been absolute horse frozen evening
I won't
I regret to inform you that the board
feels you can no longer hold your
obligations you're relieved of all
duties I want you to concentrate on your
life I've never been in love
don't say why because this is a bit
do you want a [ __ ] or therapist get out
get out get out
if you could just answer a few questions
and be honest please are you recording
this because that's not in our contract
and I'm half naked let me get a little
up how long will this take for more than
15 minutes okay could you just say your
name where you're from no well I need
basic info no you did hey what a miss
Roma's guys came looking for you earlier
you can't hide forever
you hear me sorry excuse the mess I'm in
transition right now do you uh you need
a place to stay my bread stop okay how
did you get into your field my field
prostitution a man paid me to have sex
with him not around anyway you can take
care of yourself die your wife does
okay come on you like what you do
I like being good at what I do when I'm
with a client I'm exactly what they want
not what they say they want not what
they think they want I'm what they don't
know they won't though I want you want
someone to come in here and [ __ ] all
over your world
what's worst thing that's ever happened
to you how much time I forgot no you're
wrong I am only trying to help you no
idea how to help
you're a fall over the client
you